ça y est les 120 premiers passagers ont
quitté le parc de la chute Montmorency
direction Baie-Saint-Paul à bord du
train propulsé à l'hydrogène une
première en Amérique la première journée
le premier train de passager c'est
vraiment quelque chose de spécial savoir
qu'on fait partie de ça je suis maniaque
des trains
uniquement un événement qui fascine les
passagers un accomplissement pour
l'équipe du train de Charlevoix après un
an et demi travail ici c'était
l'archipel de Montmagny une quinzaine
d'employés ont dû être formés pour
manœuvrer les nouveaux wagons nos trois
autres instants européen la conduite
c'est la même chose le vraiment le défi
ça a été vraiment de bien comprendre
l'hydrogène toutes les systèmes qu'on a
qui sont beaucoup plus modernes juste
pour les les portes les freins d'urgence
les SOS en faisant ça pour les commandes
aussi c'est on n'est plus on est
vraiment plus sur les vieilles commandes
qu'on avait
cet hiver le croient et deux autres
conducteurs de Charlevoix se sont rendus
en Allemagne pour être formés la
formation se déroulait en Allemagne
on avait une traductrice avec nous le
train est très facile à conduire plus
facile je dirais que les plus anciens
modèles c'est très agréable je dirais
peut-être comparer quelqu'un qui a une
voiture à essence des années 70-80 puis
il tombe dans une Tesla pour le
fabricant Alstom cette collaboration
avec le train de Charlevoix est une
vitrine inédite en Amérique pour sa
technologie c'est un train électrique
mais son énergie électrique elle est
produite par des piles à combustible
qu'on appelle et son carburant c'est de
l'hydrogène puis la combustible
réservoir sont sur le toit tout est sur
le toit tout le système de propulsion
électrique et batterie c'est sous le
plancher du train le corps radial Eileen
fera 80 allers-retours dans Charlevoix
jusqu'en septembre il poursuivra ensuite
sa route ailleurs sur la planète pour
d'autres démonstrations ici Flavie
Sauvageot Radio-Canada Baie-Saint-Paul